as someone who's very into fitness and
self-development I sometimes find it
disheartening reading comments online
look at that overweight guy taking the
elevator instead of the stairs look at
those NPCs with no drive to better
themselves man I hate that expression we
can do better for starters there's the
obvious anything could be going on in
those people's lives they might have
illness they might have injury they
might be depressed you know you can be
overweight and still be in good health
maybe these people have better mental
health maybe they have great Mobility
but beyond even that it might just be
that Fitness isn't a large priority for
them you know those people could just as
easily turn to me and say I can't
believe that guy doesn't speak another
language yet but it's so obviously
beneficial for you maybe they get their
sense of purpose from their friends and
family maybe they enjoy these smaller
things in life heaven forbid that
somebody be content arguably that's the
much more adjusted and healthy way to be
rather than wanting to be Batman
everyone can benefit from being in
Better Health that's as far as it goes
and they shouldn't push your goals and
interests onto other people and make
assumptions about them as a result at
the heath death of the universe no one
is going to care that you built six-pack
abs